foreign
on this Friday night from Pariah to
Alberta's next premiere
[Laughter]
Danielle Smith wins the race to replace
Jason Kenney his Reflections if I were
to go back and her pledges for the road
ahead nuclear Armageddon the U.S
president's ominous warning to the world
about the war in Ukraine help wanted the
new tactics to recruit employees
thinking outside of the box is is an
important thing to do and the newcomers
to Canada already Landing work plus Take
Me Out to the Ball Game I just love the
Jays so much
Toronto hits a fever pitch
global national with Farah Nasser
[Music]
good evening thanks for joining us it is
quite the story from political exile to
Premier Danielle Smith has reinvented
herself right into Alberta's top job
she's the new leader of the ruling
United conservative party and will lead
until at least May when the next
provincial election will be held what's
unclear is Alberta's future with Smith
at the helm and whether some of her
attention grabbing promises like a
sovereignty act become reality now even
though Smith hasn't been shy about her
hostility to Ottawa and the Prime
Minister as Heather York's West reports
she doesn't see herself as a divisive
figure
please welcome the next Premier of our
Province Danielle Smith
eight years ago few Alberta political
Watchers would have seen this coming I'm
back
as political comebacks go Danielle
Smith's is one for the books
in 2014 the then leader of the
opposition Wild Rose party made a move
so deeply unpopular she became a pariah
after crossing the floor to merge with
the governing Progressive conservatives
Danielle Smith's political career
appeared over
thank you
until Thursday night in Calgary when it
roared back to life
Daniel Smith won but she didn't win by a
huge margin it was actually a bit of a
nail biter I think
um and she didn't win until the sixth
ballot
with just over 50 percent of 85 000
ballots Smith becomes Alberta's Premier
without the Mandate of the province My
First Choice was not Daniel Smith but uh
now that we've
uh God or we've we've got to get behind
her I've heard good things and bad
things about Janelle
but uh
this is what the people want and let's
hope we're not wrong I am concerned I am
concerned uh you know I'm a proud
calgarian I love Alberta uh but above
all else I'm a Canadian but the
celebratory period for Danielle Smith
will have to be a short one there is
just seven months until albertans head
to the polls an NDP leader former
Premier Rachel notley is hoping to make
a political comeback of her own
Smith has made it plain that the real
issues Alberta families are struggling
with are of no interest to her instead
she's preoccupied with a so-called
sovereignty act with the focus squarely
on a new premier and her new plans
no longer
Alberta asked permission for
the provincial election campaign
is unofficially begun Heather urik's
West Global News Calgary
and later we'll have an exclusive
broadcast interview with outgoing
Premier Jason Kenney who outlines why he
thinks his leadership ultimately failed
Nike is the latest brand to cut ties
with Hockey Canada over its handling of
sexual assault allegations at the same
time the Prime Minister wasn't mincing
words saying Canadians have lost
confidence in the organization's
leadership and he's calling on those at
the top to step aside
if these individuals continue to be
deluded enough to think that there is a
pathway forward for them to continue to
run Hockey Canada
then Canadians will have no choice but
to look for another structure to run our
national winter sport
I think about seven million dollars a
year comes from the federal government
that money has now been frozen corporate
sponsorships had accounted for just over
one quarter of its funding
Health Canada has approved the use of
another bivalent booster
the Pfizer biotech vaccine is the first
to Target the two most prevalent strains
of the virus circulating in Canada the
shot targets the Omicron ba4 and ba5
subvariants as well as the original
strain of the virus is authorized for
use as a booster dose in people 12 years
of age and up and doses are expected to
start arriving in Canada next week
after three straight months of losses
the Canadian economy is finally creating
jobs
according to statistics Canada 21 000
jobs were added last month that pushed
the unemployment rate down to 5.2
percent but the labor market remains
extremely tight in this country and as
Ann gaviola explains that's forcing some
employers to come up with creative ways
to find workers
in September employment among men and
women aged 25 to 54 increased as many
parents returned to the workforce with
kids back in school the jobless rate
dropped wages went up signs of a labor
market that stretched it's extremely
tight and it's been tight since a lot of
those covid restrictions have been
lifted the labor squeeze has forced
employers to get creative during Peak
summer season when its Staffing
requirements nearly double
Ottawa Embassy Hotel turned to Facebook
groups to recruit newcomers from Ukraine
Ukrainian workers have been a godsend to
us there were learning curves and
language barriers but nothing patience
and Google translate couldn't solve
working outside of your comfort zone
thinking outside of the box is is an
important thing to do Canada has nearly
1 million job vacancies and the federal
government is looking to ease the labor
shortage by lifting off-campus work caps
for international students we're lifting
the limit of 20 hours per week that
eligible students are allowed to work
off campus while studying this means
that more than 500 000 International
students who are already here in Canada
are going to be eligible to work more if
they choose to do so the immigration
Minister says eligible foreign Nationals
can also work while waiting for a new
permit or extension the central bank has
said the tight labor market is partly to
blame for red-hot inflation going as far
as suggesting employers think twice
before raising wages those remarks
angering Union Representatives fighting
for pay increases as the cost of living
erodes spending power with high
inflation uh the pressure to pass along
to to workers is getting stronger and
stronger and the more that uh that
businesses resisted the harder it is for
them to find labor the Bank of Canada is
hoping to avoid a wage price spiral
where inflation pushes wages higher in
turn pushing prices higher but worker
shortages tilt bargaining Dynamics in
favor of employees over employers and of
Yola Global News Toronto
Canadians whose deaths are not imminent
may still qualify for medically assisted
dying after eligibility was expanded
last year more than ten thousand of
those individuals decided to end their
lives in 2021 that's up 32 percent from
2020 and now there are concerns about
the potential for Unnecessary deaths
tomorrow on the new reality Marion
domain looks at a population in crisis
Canadians living with disabilities who
are living in poverty
imagine being hit with a debilitating
illness and trying to live on 12 or 1300
a month while the cost of everything
else continues to rise that's the Grim
reality for 1.5 million Canadians with
disabilities who are living in what
Advocates called legislated poverty I
don't I was making good money 80 85
Grand here Les Landry was a truck driver
a decade ago that is until a Cascade of
health issues hit this is my blister
pack a hernia blood pressure epilepsy
and mini strokes took away his ability
to work that's for a week it's gotten so
bad Landry has decided to apply for made
or medical assistance in dying but not
because of the pain like in my case the
problem is not really the disability it
is the poverty experts have warned that
Canada put people with disabilities like
Landry in Jeopardy by expanding access
to made without expanding financial and
social supports first we're getting rid
of this idea that we'll first try the
least interventionist measures we've
forgotten I think the seriousness of
ending the life of a person as a measure
to relieve their suffering and he says
the government failed to implement basic
safeguards that exist in other countries
with medically assisted dying laws like
requiring patients and doctors to
exhaust all other support and treatment
options first
Landry's message to Canadians he is not
suicidal but he simply can't afford to
live I don't want to die I just can't
see me living
like this for the rest of my life there
may be help on the horizon for some
disabled Canadians legislation to
establish a new federal disabilities
benefit is before Parliament but it
won't help Les Landry he turned 65 in
May and the benefit will not apply to
seniors Marianne domain Global News
for a deeper look at the poverty crisis
facing Canadians with disabilities watch
the new reality Saturday at 7 right here
on global
the federal government says it's buying
historic land at Juno Beach to save it
from development Canada's partnering
with France and will contribute about 4
million dollars to keep the battlefield
from turning into condos a developer had
planned to build a 70-unit housing
complex on the site under the deal the
area will be protected in a 99-year
lease Juno Beach is where hundreds of
Canadian soldiers died on D-Day in the
second world war the veterans affairs
minister says some parcels of land
should never be touched never
they championed human rights and
democracy coming up the activists
awarded this year's Nobel Peace Prize
stunning comments from the U.S president
suggesting Russian threats to use
nuclear weapons in Ukraine have put the
world on the brink of Armageddon Joe
Biden's remarks were made behind closed
doors last night and serve as a dire
warning the Russia Ukraine war could
quickly trigger a much wider conflict
our Washington bureau chief Jackson
prosco joins us now Jackson what exactly
did Biden say
pharah the American president made it
clear he does not think Vladimir Putin
is joking with threats to use nuclear
biological or chemical weapons in
Ukraine because in Joe Biden's words
Russia's military is quote significantly
underperforming Biden told the crowd at
a private fundraiser in New York we have
not faced the prospect of Armageddon
since Kennedy and the Cuban Missile
Crisis the concern of course is that an
increasingly desperate Russia May deploy
a tactical nuclear weapon in Ukraine
something to counter the Staggering
losses Russian forces have faced Biden
told the crowd I don't think there is
any such thing as the ability to easily
use a tactical nuclear weapon and not
end up with Armageddon today the White
House is trying to calm concerns
suggesting there's no change in U.S
nuclear posture and no new intelligence
suggesting Russia is prepared to launch
a nuclear weapon still the concern is
that a cornered Vladimir Putin may act
in unpredictable ways in fact the
Washington Post reports that U.S
intelligence now believes Putin has
recently been confronted by someone in
his own Inner Circle in an apparent
disagreement over Putin's handling of
the war in Ukraine the criticism was
considered significant enough that it
was included in President Biden's daily
intelligence briefing pharah it all
suggests there's potentially significant
turmoil within the Kremlin and that only
bolsters those fears that Russia under
Putin May resort to unpredictable
actions
certainly Jackson prosco in Washington
thank you
the federal government is hitting Iran
with tough new sanctions condemnation is
growing over its violent Crackdown on
people protesting the death of Masa
amini today in Iranian Coroner's report
says she died from organ failure not
blows to her body
the coroner says a heart disorder linked
to an old surgery caused a meaning to
lose Consciousness the 22-year-old died
in custody last month after being
detained by Iran's so-called morality
police she was accused of not fully
covering her hair and wearing
inappropriate attire her family claims
she was beaten by officers today Canada
declared more than a thousand members of
Iran's revolutionary guard inadmissible
for life
we're invoking rarely used measures that
have been used against some of the most
murderous regimes in the world whether
it was around the Rwandan Genocide or
war crimes in Bosnia to apply them to
this murderous Iranian regime
Trudeau also vowed to improve Canada's
ability to enforce sanctions announcing
the creation of a new sanctions Bureau
with global Affairs Canada and providing
an additional 76 million dollars to that
group and the RCMP
this year's Nobel Peace Prize puts the
spotlight on human rights democracy and
peaceful coexistence of neighbors who
are now embroiled in war as Crystal
gemancing Reports the prize is being
shared between a jailed Belarusian
activist and human rights groups from
both Russia and Ukraine all prominent
critics of Russian President Vladimir
Putin and his allies
war crimes against ukrainians have been
reported from bucha to yazum and the
horrors are being documented one agency
has been at the Forefront of that deeply
disturbing work I'm calling you on
behalf of the Norwegian Noble committee
the center for civil liberties will be
awarded the Nobel Peace Prize
it's incredible seriously the Ukrainian
group is being honored alongside the
Russian Human Rights group Memorial it
was forced to cease official operations
last year after being labeled a foreign
agent imprisoned Bella Russian activist
Elise billiatsky is also being honored
I'm glad that Noble committee also
recognized human rights Defenders from
Ukraine and Russia because the fight
against two vicious dictators okashenka
and Putin is the fight for democracy for
all the world the exiled belarussian
opposition leader called beliotsky a
national hero and hope the award would
remind the world that he and others are
languishing in prison for speaking out
the community of Human Rights Defenders
of people who protect people from
different countries is the most
important Community says one member of
Memorial Group
in Ukraine especially on social media
Talk of the award is mixed with anger
few Russians or belarussians have spoken
out against the war and Ukraine is being
recognized for work as a result of the
Russian invasion
this prize gives us inspiration and an
understanding that the direction of our
work is important for building peace
democracy and freedom in Ukraine Crystal
gabencing Global News London
I had the tale of two premiers Alberta's
outgoing and in incoming leaders share
their Visions for the province
outgoing Alberta Premier Jason Kenney
has some idea about why he was ousted
from his job and he's sharing those
reasons in a broadcast exclusive exit
interview both Kenny and his successor
Premier designate Danielle Smith sat
down with our Mercedes Stevenson for
interviews airing on the west block this
Sunday with a preview here's our Abigail
Beaman
some of what I see now what I call it
populism with a snarl is not
conservatism it it's about tearing
things down and blowing things up and
that concerns me Jason Kenney points to
social media Donald Trump anger and
conspiracy theories as contributing
factors to this kind of populism kovid
put that on steroids covid a big reason
for Kenny's treble on top he tried to
find the middle ground on restrictions
but angered both sides and flip-flopped
while his conservative Premier colleague
in Ontario in similar shoes ended up
with a strong majority though Doug Ford
kicked out members of caucus who
disagreed I you know if I were to go
back I think I would have taken a more
traditional Harper or Ford approach to
managing those internal issues
as for what he'd like to see in the
party in his wake I think a conservative
party or government
that is focused on a campaign of
recrimination over covet politicizing
science uh entertaining conspiracy
theories campaigning with Q Anon is a
party that can't form government and
shouldn't
not necessary recriminations from the
incoming Premier but
stop any new coveted lockdowns and
legislating against discrimination for
the unvaccinated are top of Danielle
Smith's list we're going to make sure
that there is no worker who gets fired
from their job because they have made a
medical choice about being vaccinated
and we can do that in our jurisdiction
we are not going to be enforcing Federal
lockdown measures or federal
restrictions of course her most
publicized promise a call for Alberta
sovereignty in the face of Ottawa as
critics and constitutional experts Sound
the Alarm we are going to make sure that
we push back against their invasion of
our jurisdiction which they do all the
time without a seat yet it will be a
while before Smith can make legislative
change she now says she wants to start
by reforming the province's Health Care
System people will see that we are
serious about fixing the problem that we
have with rural ambulance as well as the
the long waiting list happening in
emergency rooms having to defeat six
other candidates and not until the sixth
ballot party Unity will also be a
question as caucus figures itself out
Smith maintains she feels supported
Abigail Beeman Global News
Ottawa
next home field advantage for the Blue
Jays is playoff baseball returns to
Toronto
[Music]
Easter Island's iconic stone statues
have been damaged by a forest fire the
fire was caused by a nearby volcano and
more than a hundred hectares having
charred on the remote island since
Monday the Island's home to hundreds of
giant Polynesian Stone heads known as
the moai that were carved centuries ago
authorities are still assessing the
damage but there is concern it may be
irreparable
Canada's only major league baseball team
is on deck for a pretty exciting weekend
for the first time in six years the
Toronto Blue Jays are playing a
post-season game in front of fans the
team is facing off against the Seattle
Mariners in a best of three Wild Card
series Mike Chevrolet is touching base
with fans who are gearing up for another
Blue Wave
[Music]
fanatic uh yeah 11 year old Logan
Nicholson Decked Out head to toe in Blue
Jays gear qualifies I just love the Jays
so much and if a home run ball comes his
way he has his priorities would you push
your dad out of the way to ball yeah
Logan is too young to remember when the
Jays became a national Obsession in
2015.
to summarize it was nuts
Jay's jerseys and hats everywhere and
while this is an entirely new team
they've been told there's a lot of guys
you know who work in the organization
who have pretty much all all they talk
about is you know that 15 16 run where
the Roger Center felt like it was going
to fall over that same fever has yet to
grip the fandom it's more like the
sniffles at this point veteran
broadcaster Buck Martinez who missed
part of the Season fighting cancer
expects a repeat it will be the same
sort of vibe no question about it it's
been six years since they've hosted a
postseason game in this ballpark will
the Blue Wave catch on across the
country like it has for Tara Mason it's
a good look right what do you think of
your mom dressing up with this uh cool
if the team wins it would be hard to
knock the Jays off their perch the
hockey season starts next week and it
does microwave Global News Toronto
what a way to end that and that's global
national for this Friday night I'm
foreign Asser on behalf of our whole
crew I want to thank you so much for
spending part of your evening with us
tonight's your Canada is Kamloops BC and
we love senior Canada so please keep
emailing us those photos to viewers at
globalnational.com until tomorrow take
care of yourselves and each other good
night
[Music]